hey youtubers is Charlie so a lot of
cool stuff happening behind the scenes
at Game of Thrones season seven there's
so new evidence to suggest that we might
get some Daenerys Sansa stuff happening
in the future so this is going to be a
predictions video just careful for
spoilers for all the stuff that's
happened on the show so far everybody
wants to see Jon Snow meet up with
Daenerys it looks like that might not
happen to like the very end of the
season if not get pushed to the season
after that but we will get to see a
union between the wolf and the dragon
it's just you know not the wolf that
you're thinking of it seems like Sansa
is the one who's going to be treating
with Daenerys via Brienne and Davos
looks like a change milady you have a
keen military mind part
so like the watchers people and the
other people that are camping the sets
in the ruins where they're shooting the
dragon pit scenes make it seem like
there's going to be a meeting with
Daenerys and people from the north but
supposedly it's only going to be Brienne
and Davos and Brienne serve Sansa she
doesn't serve Jon Snow so you kind of
think about the scene between Yara in
tenaris last season in the way she was
the one to engineer that alliance I mean
that's kind of unfair because Theon can
barely put two sentences together since
he's kind of thrown away his reek
persona he slowly clawing his way back
to being normal but he's never going to
be completely whole again so he kind of
recognizes that Yara is the better
person to lead at least from the
Ironborn perspective so she's the one to
treat with Daenerys I'm up for anything
you know tenaris kind of [ __ ] at her
head ooh that's an interesting thought
and they just have a little bit of fun
it turns into pure fanfiction after that
because you're like oh they're probably
gonna get it on in return I expect you
want me to support your claim to the
throne of the Iron Islands you're my
claim yes what's wrong with you I'm not
fit to rule your unns offer is also an
offer of marriage you see you and get
one without the other and I imagine your
offer is free of any marriage demands I
never demand but I'm up for anything
really no more
[Music]
but now you have a similar scene in the
dragon pit which looks like it's
happening relatively late in the season
where Daenerys has to deal with the
north so Jon Snow you know very lovable
person not the best at politicking so
that seems like a good opportunity for
salsa to step up just via Brienne and
Davos to send them to see what the
hell's going on with this new invading
force that they've learned about because
the maesters are probably still
operating out of the Citadel so
everybody be getting Ravens about what's
going on at King's Landing and hearing
about Daenerys verse Cersei so naturally
a bunch of dragons enter King's Landing
and you have an army in the north you're
gonna want to send some people down to
check it out so it seems like Shawne
says the person behind that like the
voice of reason but even though I do
think will you know see like Jon Snow
Daenerys moments I feel like most of
those will happen on the battlefield
because george RR martin always has like
moments and characters that seem like
they're echoes of the past not just like
completely recycling plots that happen
previously but it seems like they're
going to be honoring moments on the show
from robert's rebellion so it seems like
they're having a little bit of fun with
the idea of Jon Snow being an amazing
warrior like Robert but not so great
with ruling and that was sonses early
objection like sophie Turner has talked
about that when she's talking about
season 7 stuff Sansa feels like Jon Snow
is great just not the greatest at the
actual management of the kingdom you and
your trusted advisors and you sit around
making your plans on how to defeat a man
you don't know I lived with him I know
the way his mind works I know how he
likes to hurt people
does it ever once occur to you that I
might have some insight you're right you
think he's going to fall into your trap
he won't he's the one who lays traps
he's overconfident he plays with people
he's far better at it than you he's been
doing it all his life I'm what have I
been doing all my life playing with
broomsticks
I fought beyond the wall against worse
than Ramsay Bolton I've defended the
wall from worse than Ramsay but you
don't know him we'll never get him back
Rickon is ned stark's trueborn son
which makes him a greater threat to
Ramsey than you a bastard only a girl as
long as he lives Ramsey's claim to
Winterfell will be contested which means
he won't live long I can't give up on
our brother listen to me please
he wants you to make a mistake of course
he does what should I do different I
don't know I don't know anything about
battles just just don't do what he wants
you to do
nice good advice you think that's
obvious so if you're gonna have to treat
with another big invading force
naturally the person who's better at
politicking is going to step forward for
that moment so you have like Sansa via
Brienne and Davos but I don't think the
series is like completely throwing men
under the bus or anything like that I
think it's just having a little bit of
fun with the idea that a bunch of
terrible decisions were made during and
after Robert's rebellion and they don't
want to repeat that so you have all
these female characters seizing power
like Cersei always felt like she was
better at being in charge than Jaime was
and Jaime never showed any interest in
it growing up really rudderless person
Cersei was the one with the drive but
because she was a woman she was kind of
used as a pawn married off to form
alliances but now she sees power
obviously we have Cersei verse Daenerys
so this all seems like it's happening
after that so not you know not to
address that just focusing more on the
female characters on the show and all
the different storylines seizing power
so we still have your on floating around
we don't know quite what's happened to
him yet but I do think it's funny that
like even though you have like terrible
male characters like you're on like he's
supposed to be a villain you have good
male characters like Jon Snow they're
still being treated the same in their
own storylines like you are amazing as
smashing stuff but we actually need to
have a conversation here so you go sit
down and we'll let the women take care
of this
which makes you think of that super
slashy fanfic ending to Game of Thrones
bittersweet like all the male characters
die off including Jon Snow at the
nearest Sansa Yara just end up in like a
sex pile on one of their beds
you think they [ __ ] know they'll be
hilarious I can't wait to see the
fanfiction when we get to season eight
but I do think when we get to the end of
season seven we will have Daenerys
learning about the threat of the White
Walkers and treating with the Starks
like okay so this problem is taken care
of in King's Landing the immediate
threat so now we can deal with the
threat up in the north because I think
the big complex the season seven is
going to be the Cersei battle the White
Walkers of course will be the big threat
of the final season but give me all your
Daenerys sorts of predictions in the
comments do you think that salsa is
going to be the one to win Daenerys over
not Jon Snow just because it seems like
that's what she's going to be good at
Jon Snow doesn't seem like he is super
hot on listening to directions what
should I do different I don't know I
don't know anything about battles just
don't do what he wants you to do Jon
Snow don't charge the battlefield
whatever you do don't charge seas Rickon
charges immediately so whatever the
drama is between Jon Snow and sods I
know everybody's like are they gonna get
married that's like a whole other thing
I don't think that that's gonna stick
although I do think that that will come
up because people who see the king in
the north will want an heir so they'll
be like what you need to have a baby now
in in order to have a legitimate baby
you have to get married to someone of
noble blood so that's gonna be a whole
other level of craziness it would be a
pretty big WTF if they married Jon Snow
to Sansa but you have to wonder what
Littlefinger is gonna do in all this
because he seems like he has his hooks
in Sansa pretty good so unless he can
get Sansa to marry Jon Snow and then
kill him off somehow I don't think he's
going to be too hot on the idea of them
getting married but there the current de
facto rulers of the north or Coe rulers
so just remains to be seen but I
wouldn't be surprised if they push that
till later in the season but
congratulations to this week's Game of
Thrones winner arena destroyer you win a
$20 Amazon gift card be sure to private
message be on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
is a new round of the game of Thrones
giveaway starting now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video if there any other
bonus videos you guys want this next
week just let me know in the comments
we're not going to get more footage for
Season seven for a long time but there's
still like a whole bunch of
stuff happening on the set they still
have a lot of filming left to do but
most of the big main actors have come
back to set like Aria is on set even the
little bear is back so I might do a
video for some of those other characters
next but really big stuff happening
right now we're getting ready to start
Walking Dead Season seven the AMC people
sent me an e can bat so I'm expecting
the HBO people to send me a dragon next
year when season seven starts we'll see
if they deliver I'll hold my breath on
that and see how quickly I pass out
a lot more Marvel DC coming this weekend
so I'll just try and post that stuff as
quick as possible well you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for my
Arya Gendry video and you can click here
to rewatch that season 7 teaser trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you